>>PER. M STHERAK, IDPRE ES
F
UNTHE EDITTE STA
S.
USPP[ALA
[A
USLAE]
>>RSEM MBE OCOTHF E ,RENGSS
I  G TVEHEATREURLE PAS
E
PHIGHGEVIRILEA AN, D CTSTDIIN
RSD ANPEONALON HORF  OTIESPREN
O
Y P TOUHENTSIREDEF TH
SITUNED
TETAS.
PP[A
USLAE]
ESPR.THONIX: U.K ANYO
MYLE COL DUEAGS,UITIISNGEDSH
TSGUESELMY,  FWLOCAME ARI
O
S DRADEST JOA INN SSSEIO
IRENGSSTHN IS GHAATRE CERMBCO
CH WINHI W IASE ONCUB PSHLIED- -
EGIVPRILSE TEDO  AE RVASNON H
R
ICR FOWHI'H'LYDEM EPFURA GTE
IITSSU UN LYAL AONCAOCSI A FOR.
DENDEDIL AEN LHYGTIS LTF O
WHREHE T P HDESINT
COACEDLIMPSHN IASHE T PS
AD
WHATNTE  HWACOTHS E  TRENGSSDOO
F TINHEURUTE, I ANDANN
ONECELTIEA YR, LOLHE T P
L
ESISSU MHI WCHDE BAYE  ISICIVE
H
.FAE LL
ONCAOCSIHELYAL TES CREOME T AIM
WHUNRO PFOFAAND D HIRER-AC
NG
ENEVTSAN DEMDAK B AREN I
ADITN.
S ISTH I TCHSU AE.IM
I ISY SATHNLOT N OYSEEC BAU
S MARKA NEWAD DECHIINE  W
WIICERA EB CLLELTSTERA I00 2HAM
HDBIRT, AYI SAU BAYEC
NSEW
LEKNOWD E DGANXPRDHA EEIEERNC
EARGU PIVSUERASATY ELTHAROT BH
MSOGPRRAURND A OTUNS ITIINONTIS
AMEDA ICNEO  TBEER PCTFE- -
NEO T BRMREE FO.ED
MEE THMO HNTASIV ARR
TEDO
ESHARNVATHS E RG ESTNEY
AND
DAABUN TE NCOFSHI L TD ANTO
HER
TIEAONF O A N AEWNRIMECA
EX.ENRICE
XPAN EEIEERNCHE RICDEANR D
,
D ANAEF RN CTLEIO G TOFHESDNOOES
OFAN HHEUMT.PI SRI
THE97 1S'0'E LLWI B OTIA MEF N
GIBE, INNNGSTIA MEF OLO EXPNGRIW
E D ANTHANRTEAH ENHED AV
S.A
ME OVEIS DCOT , RYBUETH
ASMETI HE  COMPHR FOEMNISAS O
DE BPILONGTEETRS  WAY
WGINANGT HAWEE, HAVND A OFMA
COTILENGHA WTAN MS''NIGEUSAS H
IDONE ULEF FTHEINNFIS
NDR OULATH, IS LATD ANTHRSS  IOU
GETOS ERTH IARE GATND A
OO D
.LAND
ITS  IN SOAL ASHFIUNNIED
A,
THAND LECHE ALENGF  OTIRFPEEC
T
S I
97HE T 1S'0'
WI IITS T  TTHHA TIRSPIT
T I
DRADS ESMY IADUESSS NGESDRSI
R
TEAIO NATH WHN ICOVE ARAB
EPA
ISANIP.
ENWHE  WOFEASPK CAME ARI''
PR, TIRIESRSE THFI
MUT ST
YSALWAE B PORCEEA FRI AME
D
WOTHE D.RL
[AE]LAPPUS
JOE THMADIIMR MEALE ATGOF OUR O
N REFOIG ILIPOCYRITOS  B
AN
D EN W TTOHE IARNAMIE VTNYNY AWA
THUR OATEN GERLLN IOWIE B
ERMEREMBT , EDNOH MSOUCTH AS
ONRANETISUHA TT  IERFFEDN, WAREE
BUORREMO FHE T FATT ACTHE W
HA C TVEHE ARAOUGENDHA C
CR
TO W K TINHED INOF PHACEEA T
TTH
E NNET EXGE WTIRAONE  AASBL
O
.KEEP
LA[APPE]
AWEIN MREAKREPRG OGAR TSSOW
DTH
L. GATOA
THESP PROORTSEC F PRECEEA AAR F
R EAGRTEDATOYHA TARA N YE
G.
JOA MA OPAR RTTHF E CDIT R
THIS DMEELEVOPS  GNTOE
TTE
ERMEMBHIOFS  TS CSGRONES, W,HO
E SPDEITDIEITHR CEERFFENHEONS  T
CO TT UCOFHE W,
AV HE
WHOVERLYMIELNGATND IICIR TEDHE
SUT OROF AUS JTEA P.CE
HIBY TS A YIOCTN,OUE HAV
CO DTELELYHEOLEMISD
THE
Y'ENEMH'S ATS PETHCAHE TY NAI G
N
ASIN WN NGHITOCTE THVIRY OROU
FINGTIASEN M H D--ANEMD AV HE
TNIDEED VM HEIN.TNIEAM
[A
USLAE]
NO GULL OACOREBED  GHAERAT TTON
HEKEMA TEX NT GIOERENAT
THNE
T FIRS TOFHE C ITUENRYHWHN IC
AMS A ICWAAT WEA PCEERH ITEV
A
N ONTI IETHOR W.LD
LSHI ALIS DN SSCU I TTADEIL
HEE
EPCOW NC ATSNDAMRO PGR
EDSIDEGNHIO  TACISE EVTHL GOA
N
PAA SEEPTERA R FT ORON
EION
, LIPOCYIICWHH HA SLLMI SUBTOT
E CORESSLAT  AA RTEE. DAT
T LEMEIBES DCRDITHE E NSCTREIO
OFUREW NIEOL PICY.TOS DA
AVWE HD BAE SELIR OUPOESCI OANN
UAEVALF ONTI OE WODIT AS
IS IT NOAS25WAT S EA YRSGO A
C TATHEIOCLONUSNF  OWARLWOD
RI
NYTH OF CIPOE LIE WESER
SSNECEDY ARAN RHEHTIG T
BUNT
LEOBSOAY TTEOD
BEENTH, USCAEERF  OAMA'I'
SOV
MIWHERELNO ENGCODC MIAN
MIRYTA SH,ENTRGTSEEC BAUF O
E THAKNE OF FRHEOTR LD WEEOR
WEPOD , RSANETHLINA IBITYF O
NDDEINPETEN N TIOATNSOEN DEFD O
GEVENEROVNELHE TMSMES,VE ACARIR
D HATOE SS AUMJOE THMAR B
DN
E R FOTHE FEDENSED FOFREOM I
NTH
D.WOE RL
INWO WARST FS,IRN I, OR KEADAN
VW NOIN, TNIEAMWEAV HE
HERNFUIS OMOD STMOTHF E Y,NE
NDMSAR A MENHE TO ER OLPTH
NAFES ONDEIR TNDHEOMRE FED
.
TDATOY,HEAT GRETRND IUSLIA
S TINAONOF E AOPURE,WES LLS  A
O
PAN,AV HENEEG RAIRTHD EI
ECTRICOM SGTH,ND T
HE ACD
OFONTIS AT LINRI AME
MANYTH OF ONNAE TIWHS OUI ACQDRE
FREITHR AFDOEEM RTE CLIONOLIA
F
RLR TEWOWAD R IIAV HWA E NE
SERIOFE  P AND D,NIIGTY
D
A DNAERETMIOONTI T A
UMSSE
ONRESPTYBISILIHEOR F TIR
OWN
NSDEFE
ATTHE S  ITHOFSIBAS HE T
NECTDORIOU A INNTEDNC AUA G
M.
HENEITR TEN DHEEF
OSER
LODEVEOFENPMT  NTH OER CIOATNS
E
LU EXC OVESILYRRI P ARIMALY
NM
UICERANKIERNDTA.NG
USPP[ALA
TH
NSAT NIOCHF  OEAOFAR PT HE T
SHRLWOD LDOU AUMSSE P THE
Y
ONRESPTYBISILIHEOR F T
OIN
-BWELLNGEI, DAN THE TY,VEMSHEEL
O
MIET DER T TNEHEF MSER OATTH
EILLWE-B.NG
SWEELLHA BFUAI FTHURTOL  O
COS,MEITNTEUT B W SEDLLHA REUC
ROUOL INVMEVENT ASE PNDRESNT
R OTANHE'TINAONA'S
IRFAS.
LA[APPE]US
TOOTISNST TIR HENAAYS ONPL
LEROT S  INOAET RATRE
RO FMA
ONRESPTYBISILI SUT B A ORIHANG
E
BIONSPSI
TYLI.
RELT OTHISEW N PHAICOLY
EN NWE TOTO URENAK OIA ALLESNCBE
GT BUTOEIVHE TNEM WE, LIFEW N
THRESTNGA, EW N OEN SSEONCOF MM
RPOS
TIRELASSHONIPOUIT WH PEEUR RO
L
REESLI AG TR SONALD ANHEYTH
OSEBADN MUAUTLES RILNSPOIBY.IT
E HWEAVTI INI NEDAT AEW AHROPPAC
TOINATCAME ARI,N  IWEICWHH
DETHIT WH TIE OSNA
S ONAS
NEPARTHE RRSATRHA TNOTAT PRI
SH
NEE WAR PIPERTNSHPTON CCEAS H
ENBECO WEL AD MEINA.SI
E HWEAVEL DEVEDOP AORHIN ST
BANEW R S SIFOSEPAJANECAME ARIC
R
IPNDIESHND APE COO,TIRAON
WHH ITHS ECH LINR N PIFO
E
HEIN TAC P
ICIF.
WD ANIFTOARE E AV HE PCEEA
N
THIS, NT ERYR MAA JO WCTFAORLIL
D TBEHEMEELEVOPNT OF AEW N
ONLARETIETIPSH BHEENWE TDNI UTE
ST S AESNDUNIEOVT N.IO
DWOI UL NER UOTNDTETIESMAUR O
ENFFDIERUTS,CE BE E  WARVING
THWISIRE PCI P AONND FPOURSEMRO
ANFRA E OONON CFRTITAONND A
ATGONETIN.IO
GOR OUNENSATTIIORAN  OST
GIC
ARMS LIOITIMAT O ANSNDREERTH A
I
LLE  HAVGRFAA R CHTEEAR CEAN
RFO SCEUCSS IF BDEH OTSI
ARE
TIMOBYTEVAD LUT MUA
-ISELFT ERNTESTHRAERN THA
SE
TAIMNTEN
TYLI.
IITS W
H IT--
LA[APPE]US
THISE S  ITHMESAPI SRT RIFO
WHHAYOH U VEEDES RUM
DISSIUSONIT WUNCOH MMTISHI C
N
TAOUD R  WS LKAT
SAARW.
COOUR INERNCN ELUR O R
IOAS
TWITHSEHEAT NNSIOTO IS  AVO AID
CAICROSTPH CLISI T AONND
D ILA SASIDOL B P FISORLCEEAFUBU
SE.MELENT
OFIFUR O DESREFENC
WOI  TD ULBET  LHEASTOSTUG SGE
THO ADRO TISACPEE OT N
ULFFDIIC I BT,UTVEEL BIEEWUR O N
CIPOLIES HEAVTR CON TUTIBED
E
PEPROST  TCTHAA ERAMICYMAE HAV
STE THBEE HA CNCWONCSIE DRLAR W
TWTOO NJ EER GOYENIOATNF O
RRINUNTETEUPDEA PD, CEANT THA
CHILCEAN WL BMOENE ORLYUS
IND.EACRSE
E IF WUENTCOINVEO  THA
ARE
SHTILAONWE BIPETENON C
ESS
THAND ETIXE ECUS VEINHI W
ITDESPERDIE FFINCEENS LSET DAI
,
WI TTHHEITEC SUROFY  A,RIMECA
DANEAHE T P OCEFANKI
ANE
CONCNED,T E  WACTNO
AS
CRDEMOS,ATLIEP RUBBUNSCA, AST
ANERAMIC
S.[A
E]LAPPUS
VEE  WMOTHNT IO DEDEE CAF O
70E TH19S'' W THAE VEAT GHERETES
UNPOOPRTRY ITFORO PESGRSF ONY A
PELERLN  IWOORHID ST
S GRR OSALTINAON P WDUROCTLIL
SECRINEAY BBI50 $0 INIOLLN HE T
0XTNE 1 YRS.
ISTHASNC IREE,LO A G, NEIS
R
TTHANIR EHENTEWT GROHEOFH  T
AMANICCO EMYNORO FM 10O T
CRTHE ICITALIOUE QSTOTISN  N
WH WR HEWELIL GTW ROBUOW HE W
SELLWI UHA TTWT GRO
CAE THDE ODEFHE T 10'9'S,HE T
'6019'S S WASOAL A PIOERD
OF
T GREA EOWGRTHCANOCOMIY.LL
TINMET HASAAR0  1YED,ER PIOE W
SETNWIESGRTHD E  GTEEASTOFWTROH
ECRIM, EAE THGRNCSTTE IINASREE
IN TIOATN,HE GT ATREES
CL
REUNSTAM IN INICERA EA00 1 Y.RS
HAVENER AS IO NATN STOMEEED
HAAD HOR MENANE D YEJOD LSES.
AT HTHRTEA, EISE SUTH IS
E
FECTS ENIVESER GOFOVENNMT
.
HOURSASEC BS E,OM ATI CITONESNU
BTOE R AND AAIEMNSIE SOC
F
ELARGTAXP EEC
ONTI.
RNGOVENTEL HPSEN GTHATERE EOS
ATPEEXCT
NSIO.
YET,RE INCY,INASGLS T  IHA
D
LEUNAB SO  TDO
ASEO PE E,PL WOD HAT
O
VMANYIOISNSND AITWO T LETL
S.SIVION
--NOW  TOOVITLITE
ONSIS.
ASNOW TEE  WENDRE97HE T 1S'0'E W
LDSHOUER ENTMEF ROR T FOR
HECO
TITINSTUAM OONF ICAN
NTRNVEME
.[A
E]LAPPUS
PUOUR INOSRPE HI TSER PD,IO
NOUSHLDBE BOTE ANERTT MTEMAGEN
OFGR PHERO TS AMINT. PHEAS
E THASMETI HFOOM CE WA R NE
QUT.ES
ESA QUT NOT FRE AOR GERAT
TYANQUTIF WH WE VEHA, BUT
FO
W A R NEY ALQUITE  LOFIF
IO T
A RTR JOPA OTHF E SCESTUBAN
AP OOAPRCHNIORPPTUESTION C
D
ORIN MEHA TTWN O LTIISEGLA
VEPR
S,OSOPALHI WCH S IET ENTH
COASSSRE LT AEA YR,CH WNDHI
L STILENAIAWT T.TMACEN
OFI  LR FEAT DSTEA AENOZINOR ME
E TH OURCOSE STHF IS.SIESON
AT TINS HIPOO  IT, DTNO I
ED
TOROO  GTHDEH UGA  LILTAED
G
HAOF WRO IT PANSEPOD D W
T I
DWOULPO PROT, SEBU INDOMECME
THS ARE EAIN WCHHIRG UTEN
TIIOPRRIAN DESEMVERED MO. NOW
FI WT,ENO CANY DET LA INGLOER
MPACCOGSHLIIN A ROT TALOFOREFM N
OUE LFWEAR.STSYEM
USPP[ALA
SENWH APETEYSM SLINAZEK,OR
UEABRKSS,HOP ME ANDS  ROB
E
IGOF DTHTYNI,  NE ERIS
IVRNTEATE TTIADO OPIT INGN
S
PLCOE ACINMEUP SJORTPO,
NITRAI W ANGNDCEK ORIN,IVNTES
WHHEC I REDMEOMNDEO  TTH
COASSSRE L.YET AR
[A
USLAE]
MEE THTIOMAS H CE TSSASO SEND A
FORERM OTI IURNSS TITUON
NTRNVEMEE T  ATHL,DEFERATA SGO
N
L LOD CA
VELEL.
TI IITS  A FMEOREW N FISEREDAL
N
HI WCHER AFT90 1EA YE, RSTH
PO TFRR OMPL PHEEOANE DAL LOC
N
E STD ATMEVEGORN
S NTTO
INWASHONGT, I.C D., BWIT LLINEG
W  FTOLOOMFRNGAS WHINTO B
O
THETE STATHANS D LEPEE OPEF  OTH
UNTE SEDTA
S.[A
LAUS
ED,IR WUS MT
ADOOR REF
LLH ICWID XP EANNGE THRAOFE MSWH
POOPIEUNRTITALFOS R ICAML ERS.AN
ANWE C F TFIULLLRI AHEMENCA
DREA ONLWHY ENH EAC PHASOERN
IRFAE HA CNCFI FTOUL O HLLIS
N
EADRMS.
TH EEA MNSOTALQU VGINHT RIG
,Q
LUAIN VOTRTOPG POS ITUNIEDAN
POW NEOPIEUNRTITSXPOR F E
DD
RSOWNECAP HIBE OE USINO ERRD T
E
RESECUEIN  ITHNHUR MAIG RS,HT
NOPPELEDEE ATOESCCS RTRO PPE
YI
TSGH.
PP[A
USLAE]
COI VED ULGIILIMARMP EXA
F
EACH OTHF EOR REF
FMSOR
IOUCEDATN,SI HOU,NG
ORANTRSPTION O ANDERTH
ALITCRICRE AAS WFFCHHI AET ECTH
WE OEI-BNGIOMIF LL
ONSF
ICAMERS.AN
E TH OOPPELEUNTHF E EDIT S
S
LDSHOUNOAI WT R ON LGERSRTFUHE
REATS RMTHOU WLD SO --R FOU
THRMREE FOS TULT HAWOSOD
EEPDELY TANNHCELI QHEUA
OF
R THEI
FELI.
ENWHPE I SAC OAKF
ONTIS
FIBENEO ALCI TERE THAMANIC
OPPECA, LEI N OHI TNK MNOF NEE
IMTHANRTT  T FANORHEGR CONSES
N JTOOIHI TSIN MIOTRISAT
IN
THEE AT BTLTOTHTO SP EINIS RE
THF-STCO-O.VILING
[A
USLAE]
ALI RE IE IZITTITES MP
TNGO
BLE SOONE ORSEEL F
IN
IOATN.
SOME BMELAIN BUSSEESSOR F
G ISRAIN AICPRE,E  SNDOM
AME
UNORNSIO FG SK AINRFOE MOR
WA
BUT AT VIEWEF  OTHTA SIS, RTTH
LFCOAX PDEELURY ATNSMOTRRE WESHE
THRI PRYMAS LA CIMSIR FORI
NG
ESPRIC M PT USBE
CELAD.
HEIN TEEC DADF OHE T0' 196 'S,
E
GORADEL NTRNVEME $PE SNT
IOLLNOR MEITHA TN INOO TK N I7BI
XETAS.
TINMET HASAE,EC DADHE T
ANERAMICE EO PPLHEIDPA T
ILL
THFOR ATITEF DICICN  IPR
EAINCRICS SEWHE RAH ISETHE
STCOVIF--OLI T FNGORRA AHEVE
GE
MILYF O FROUY  BOR00$2 F
HSMONTN I A.RIMECA
IOMILL ONSFME A ACARINSCE FREOR
O
TOO  GINEB DTOD TAYEC BSEAU
DEE THFEVEL RAGO DMERNNT
ID
O TO GEBTOIN DT YAYTEESRD
.EREDL
WEUS MTAN BAL F OCEUR
BUO ETDG SANERAMICIEAM FIL
L
AHAVER ET BTE TANCHCENCBAO LA
H
MIR EIFAGE BLYUD
T.[A
E]LAPPUS
LYONTHIT WH ERCOE OPOFIOATN
NGCOANSSRE CE WEE MT
HI TS
ESHIGHRIPRT IOEC OTYBJVETI
OF
REBLONSPSIEER GOV
ENNMT.
WEN RE A OGHE THRITCK TRA
.WE
BAD H ADANALCEGE BUDT I
N19
.69
MTHISATISINTRUTNSIO COR ME TN
$7 B TLIILONUCPRO ODAE UR SUSPL
0, 1IN97ESND A DHATEPI T
SSNGCOREEDED RUCUEEV REN$3 BY
MILLN, I RTI SLLNDOMECME
ABA
NCLAEDGE BUDT F1. 1OR97
[A
USLAE]
BUASCAI N RESU T YOUTT HANO
LY TOSE PRE S BNTUTTHY TAWI
EDLABANCUD BQUT GEREMEE IRSO
HAIOEC DIS.NS
ITEA MNSEC REJPENGTI S
INNDG
MSOGPRRA WHI WCHENLDOU BITEF
F MESO OETHE EO PPLHEENWH T
IRE
CTEFT FELD WOUUL RESRIINT  P
INS EACRSERFO O ALLPETHF E
.
IITSIM TTOE  QTTT UIPUODG INGO
INNEMOY  P BTOADS,GRROAM
OTE,RWHEISLLE  WWIND ETHP  UWI
BAEY MONADND A BAMRO PGR
S.
LA[APPE]US
IEC RNIOGZE TICOL PIT
ALPO
TYLAPURIENF  OSPNGDIRO P
,
PAARICRTULAN ILYN IOLE ECTN
YE
,AR U BUTWEESNLS THTO SP
ERI
ISENS,RI PCEOSHE T CTF O
G IV LINLLR FOMINSIO O
WLIMIESCOL ILBEEA UMENBFA
,
D ANANE THPLDNEAMRO PGR
FOSR
REPROG T FSSORHEUT FLLE URWI
MEBECOSIMP IOSE.BL
ER RINEFNGRIO  T CDGBUETS,UT
ISERTHE NE ORE AA IHE WRE
AE
ORANREDED RE INCATE,AS RANR HETH
A
ATTHS  IETHEQ ROFSTUES
HOE
CIAGENES WEH ITTHES RILNSPOIBYIT
W R FOLAEMFOENRCT.EN
'WE'EAVE HRD A DRE GAT
L EAF
BLOVERETN OWRH-ICOR -
E]LAPPUS
'WE'EAVE HRE ARD GL  DATEA
OFOVE
NBLEROWRIHE RTOHIINC  W
WORDASAR W HFTOO T ON BENEE
USTH, E O WARNOVER,TY T
ISONR  MISY,ER DSEEA,UN HR.GEHEA
RE TIFHEE S  IONHEEAAR W
E
WORDSAR W IPRPP AROITTEIA, S I
F TINHEGAHTIG AST CME.
T  MWEUSE CLDEARDAN W TINHE W
G
THNSAIT ENARI CMIENELL EM,TS
INICWHH NGEACRSILYHR TDTEEANE
TIR OUCIME, ESHO O AS,ND
URLI
S.VE
[AE]LAPPUS
A AV HE  EAGTRIC OMPXALEFS THI
PRINLEOBM ATHE T NN'I'SALAP CIT
THRECOE NGSSND AXEHE T ESTICUVE.
HA P TVEHEMARIRYPO RESITIBNSIL
.
IBT DOU IMAF NYBEEMRSF  OISTH
SSNGCOREWH, OMOIV LE N  TREHA
AE
KSBLW OCHERO FM ,REOU W
E THERTHAVLEE REI C TS ARINLD
HEA
TAPILAG GARANE DAL W
KHO
IG TMEON.HT
ISTHEA YR,S THIDM AATISINTRNIO
TSENTCOTHO E  1RENGSS3 SEAREPAT
PI OESFEG LONLAISTINGEA DLI
WITTR SEE,RI CME NARTICS
TE IMINTR DHEIS
T ICOFCR
MBCOLU.IA
ONONEBITHF E VES LLHAEDEA RCH
MYFOES DK ATSIR GNE.UR
AMI FI CONONNTDE CWIESGRS
T
NOW TT ENO ACGIE THLENATSLIO
A
FOE STBEREASOU Y L.YET AR
WETHN ECU EXEAVVETI H
DOE
YTEVERENGHI W U CANXIERND E
G
BLAW,UTEW NTRND A S
GEONR
ONWEAPNEARS E ED ITHAT
FI
T.
PP[A
USLAE]
ITILWHE UES  ITRHA TT STEND A
LOLAL WOR ENF AMECENTSNCGEIE
AR
CUTHE E EDINTTG TH IGEN E
RTEFFOIMO  TELATE REET
CRGL BE,UR MIEARS, MDEURR,
YPR
S OSOPAL H YTOOUBOE AVEMEDDI
IE BMYEL TTHF ATER FHEEDAL
RNGOVEHONTME SAYD ULPLAT G ARE
O
WO ILEN ININRKG ERAR PTNIPSH
HETHWI TNC ASEGES.IE
ITHAT19WHS Y ER F71EDAL
SP
FDIENNGAL LOROCAW L
ENRCFOEM DWIT LLTHBLOUE AT
ETBUDG FOR970.
[A
E]LAPPUS
THY IMPRARSISPREON FLIBITYOR
TIMCRESFET HAAFIV ICTNDUAIDLS
IS
LOIT WH D L CAANRAATSTE ERTH
TH
H  WANITL DEFERAMEVEGORN.NT
TT BUINLD FHEIEGAF  OOR
ZED
E,CRIMTIAR NCORN, CSPOY,RAOGPH
TH
RAFEE DERNGOL VEASNTME H A
ILFULFL.REL SPTYBISILIOUT  ISHLD
SD ANWEMAULHOD HI WKEASTONGN,
, D.C.WEERWHE THAV HE ARPRE IMY
SISPREON, LIBITYMP EANXA TLEO
NATHE NDONTI AORHE T W OLDF
T SPREECW R FOLA TTHRAERNHA
LA
ESESWLSNS.
LA[APPE]US
W I NOO RNTU TECSUA BJWHIC
O XTNE TSIR OUDE P FREORCEEA,
MA
BWEY LLTHOMECE RMAE JO
ERCONCHEOFN  TCAME ARILEPEN OP
D TINHEOFADECE 97HE T 1S.0'
INT  NHEEXRS Y10EAALE  WSHL
IN
OEACRSELT WUREA0%BYH  5.
PRTHE  QOUOFNDN STUEIOES: ISDO
EAISTH MILWEN  W0%BEL  5RIC RHE
RIN ANSL EASE B 5E,0%OFTEETR F,
PP% 50HAR?IE
OR MS OEITATN EATHE N  ITHARYE
P T80HENTSIREDEINTA SNDING
IS PCE WOKL ILLOONAC BK  A
DE
N DECA I70ICWHH UROF%  O
PEED LLEIVTRN  IMEANOLOPIT
S AREA BOKCHEDFITRY AFC,
SU BATOCED, SMY OGEDISPOONY B
WAFE DR,EA ND NEBYANSEOI, D
IZRRTEORCR BEDY E?IM
E E ESARE T NOTHEAGRTH
TIQUESATS ONTHRNON CCEOR WLD
ATERADS T UM SMIENNFCOERS.CELE
BU DOPPELELINOO T TH AVET E
.MMSUIT
THINIV LE OOHE T F OILTHLS
FEV
EYDERAYNCERXPIE I AE,NDIST
ORMETI FF LL A OCO TUSO
ERN
ELOURSTHS VEWIAYHE T W
EA RL
LEPEOPIVE  REA.LIL FE
EAE THGRTIQUT ESTH OONF '19E 7'S
S
SHALWE SERREURNDRO  TOU
SU
INOURRND S, GSORE LLHA WKEMA
ACR OUPE NWIE THANURATE NBED GI
TOPAE AKRES TIRAONER FOTH
DAHA WGEE E  DVEON A OTOUR,IR
TOD, LURANO ND A TTER OUWAR?
LA[APPE]US
INSTREORRENAG TUS O  TITLTUNARA
ST CISE  AEYSEAU BRTD ONPAY
AN
NDBED YOONAC FTIS.
ECAS H BCOE OMA AUONMM C OSEF
E L ALTH OOPPELE CTHF IS.NTOURY
T
CAS  IA  PE USOFLATIARCUR
CO
TOERNCN  AOU YNGNSRIMECA,
USBECA MTHE EYANE ORTHLLE  WWI
RERIHE T GEQCOM NS ONCUEES
FOU
URFAR ILCTTOE  AOGN  OPRMSRA
ARICWHH EDNEE EDF OW N I AWERE
RETO PISNTVE DTER TER.
N CLEALER,AI CER WANATOP, EN
-ACSPESE TH- ES OOUSHLDENC
AGHEBEN  TRIIR BTH ET GHOFRYVE
ANERAMIC
T E  WACHEW,NO TBECAY N
TTI SLLF NKHI O FR AIASE.REWE
EAT BUCLISAIN R REOT N F AE,ND
NER ISLEAN.AT WER
E PRE IC PG TAONONLUOLTIH
ROCONTIGISL  H
OUUGROH S YER ART POFAS
CASSSSLENECUE  WIN DEDRR ATEB
TO AURATE, T NNDOWBTT HADES I
CAINBEG EDLL.
RAPRE OGALI M SHOSPRL OPTOE
COILSSRE WHEBEL  T
OS MT
RECOMPE NSHEIVSTD ANCOGR PLYRO
N
FIHI TS  AD ELIN'RIMECAS
HI
ORSTY.
S IT IPRT NOA FORAOGM  OJUR ST
E
.AR
'YEA ARP'S TH IANN LD FISIES I
N  PNOLA. AATLL
A  IISS O METI THEOKLO A NADOT
A T , ARBUEAVEFI Y10 ORSR
--ARYES VEHA WTE ITIR MES
IRREQUDO TEDO OBHE T J.
L SHI ALE OPPROSS  TTOHISSNGCORE
A IOBI0 LLONNAN TILEDEWI CAN
WAGR PRSROPU TAMO RNMOT DE
PANIMUCIE WAL STENEATRTMTSPLT AN
INLARYVE PAM ICEN WHICERA EER
THEERE A N MD DETORE AKOU
CTEWARSGAANLE AD , INAN IDOT
NOW.
LA[APPE]US
E  HWEAVDUE THIN CRISTALY,ACAPIT
IFN BEE GIO W,NO TTHILBUD
EL
INWIL THYEIV FE S.AR
ROISTH PILAMGR WTHGEL T LT BEMUI
FTHWIINARE IVYES.
ITUR O CD S IEANSBUSURB
NTRELE ESSLELY TANXPD,SEHO
ESICPREL SOPS ENNECEPAS OREDED F
RE ATIEAONCCASRE AE SIESBLTO
R THEIOPLERE SEDLLWAOWP  U--
N OFTER.REFOVE
WLEUNSSERPRE ESSE TVEHESPA SCE
WH ATHE EYLL SRETIABVA AIL,LE
ILWE W NHAL VE PE ONTOE.SERERV
TH
E,EFERORLL S IHASERO PPOEW N
INNAFINCODMEG THPUFOS R NGHARCSI
OP APA SCEKL PNDAROWDSAN N
,BE
LA[APPE]USARY E US TSTO .
THBITOAUMOOU ILES TWOR RS
POF ERUT OR.E THAI
ADONTEUA CEQOLTR RREUIS
FUVAR HEADN ESNC I
GIENNE
GNDESIUEND A FOSCOL MPIOITN.
WENTLLHA I OSIENFYEA RURESH,RC
CRT SEINLYSIEANGTTR SIC
ST ARDDAS,EN SNDTR
HEGTN
RCENFOPRENEMT ESEDOCURD -  -AN
E
L SHALNO IDOT W.
[AUSLAE]
O AN C N ANGLOERTOORFFD
COIRERID AATND A WMO CEROMN
TYOPPRER TFR, EEBUBEO  AD SEBY
ANHO WNEITAR RUTEGHETOD  T
COESUEEQNC.
INE D,EA W BOUSHLDOWINEG NO T
T TREAS EMTH A RARSCCEESOUESRC,
H
AH ICWEMO NREO E  FRERETO
COE INAMATE ANTH WEEE ARFRO T
ROW RBAG OINE TOUR
ORIGNEHBS''RDYA.
THREEQ RUIRECOS MPE NSHEIVWNE
RES.TILAON
ITQUO LSREHAESIR TTH TT,O E
EXSI PNTOSHEE,BL T ORI PCEF
SHODGOS E LDOU BO DEMA TECLINUD
THOFSTCOS CIRO PDU ANGND
OSDISP TG INOFTHM HEWIMAT OUDA
O
NVHE T ENTONIRME
.[A
E]LAPPUS
EA IW, RHAZELI TARTHT E MEGUNT
ISADENFT M TTHE ATS REHE I
AFU
TAAMNDENRACOL NTNCTDIIO
BEONN EEECROICOM GD H WTANETH
Y ALQUITE, LOFIFATO  STHVEO  THA
ONT  MWEUSE RSFOAKHEE THOTR.
TH
ERANE SWT S  INOND ATOBAON
THGROWTOBU, T ECED RIR
ITT .
FOPLEXR AMSH WE,E URLDOU T
NTO
NDRDWA ENGG INCO ATIESONND
ATIMELINOGG INSMAMHE T SE
REOFOIRVR TINV IENIU GVEENS
REATTH CHEEDAT THEINM  TIR FST
PLE.
COVIUEIND  EROGOUSCNOCOMI
POWGRTHS VIRODEH  WUSITETH
MENRTOS  EFEH ICLIF TS IELDAN
AN ETONH P OCEURASNELAT CE P ALA
HO TABITLEMAO N.
EAIDND IIVSTL UAMUT NL EIS
IH
HT FISIG IF  IITE TOS  BN.WO
ASIT HSAEE BN  THANO MTEATR
HOATNYMA NPANAIOL DS RKAN
HI MICORALTSUMONENY E  WBUDAN
P,VEDELORUHE T TNI SLYIG
CT
ROENVIFOENNMT  OEAR CHSUSF  I
THICN  IWHPEWEH  S O 8ND0%F
MER OUTIR N  IOU IMEHOS,OUN R
F ESAC OTHRKWO, ETSTE REOVS ERL
H WHICVE TWERA
ITETRE LUNR,TE RARWNDO PNGKI
ARISTPSDS YNDARPIDI, LATEDAD
, NCFEES WOKBREN, DOINWSGOKSMIN
AUS,BIMOLE WIN DGYKIORNG
ESPLACSHAL, L E LDOU BJEE THOBCT
F OOFURIESHRE VW.
E  HWEAVOOENBE TANOL TERUROFT  O
U
INOURRND T AGSNDLI WOOIL TNGO
ITAVLEE HEO  TOTCL TRSO N EAUP
ENOUR ENROVINMT.
MES  ITIHOOR F T M WSEHOEAK
E SSMAIVS MADENDIE SONOC
TO
SMAKENIE OMMIMAL MADE
S NN
SETHEMESLV.
[A
E]LAPPUS
F CHEA OT  MUSUSE SORELVATTH
EA
H DCHAY LWIE LLISVEEA H
,
PRHIS , EROPTYBLE THPUCE PICLA
F
ITHE T COWORY  TTTA N LI
LECL
ANEEAR,E IT LTL, TTBEERA
LELITTPLOR ME  FSAEANTSE HORIMLF
THAND OUE OSAR. HNDIM
WIELHE T HEOOFP  P CE PLWE
AO
INNY ATH W AG,ND THOITUTIRHE
WELPHE, O AN C DG.THNOIN
INIRS HISPGE, ITTOWEERTH, AN C
AIRECLOUR ND FS  OORURDAN
RAGENETOONTIS
OM CE.
EEBETWANNON W YETHD E 0, 2AR00
OVIL00 1 MHIONLI CWIRELDN LL
ORBE BHEINN  TD NI UTE.ATSTES
THERWHE W  GEYRO H AUPNDL, WOWIL
MOANHA TN THONY E EAG,IN MRESU
ALE THQU AY ITOFN RIMECANFELI I
THS YEE AREAAHD.
UL SISHO WBED  A TNIARNGUSO .
THFOR  3PAE STS,YE0 ARUR O
TIPUPOLA A HONASENO LSBENGRO GWI
ANNGIFSHTI.
ICAMT ERT MEA ANINMESOTHTOG
THTHRLWOD CH WENHI NOU CLDOT
BED SUEARELA DINOL,RS
INMESOTHMOFAG R OR IREMPNTTA
ILANTH MMIARITY T.GH
20AGARYES S  TO,HINAS WAA ONTI
IL 3OF MONLIEO PE,P.
TSTLIENIDPRO ESOMT ENTHAS
SOFFJEER80INN  1 A "2:WE NCTOT
ELOUR RSONS VEAL F BE,UT TORHEFO
E WHOLRAMAHUN ."CE
SAD H AALRIPITUUALI THEN
H
UGH ICCA I THTHETIGIMANA OONF
I
OIOLLNSLEPEF OPE N  ITHRLWOD.
O
HEY,DA WREWEN  AICHE T RSTHE
ANESROSTNGONNAT TIEN  ITH
WO I LD,ETBENOT T DEEC RORD
WTHAT TLAE CK MOR AND
L ITIRUASMEAIDLI MHI WCHE ADUS
PEE THHOE F  OTHATRLWOD HE T
F METI ORTR OUBIH.
DETHE OFNDMAS  1S  UINE6 97AR
EVERRE GATINHA TN 77 16.
S IT IGE LNOONGHENR OUVEO  TLI
LEAND .LIT VE
NOW  MUS ALIT VEP  HNDELVELI.
WEFRD EEA IMH ESCLE ATIN
OICERA,WH INEN PEH ICA ONRS
EAN CABREEE THFR B ALYNDATREHE
INOMRE FED.
GNRER COOFIOITN RUHE T TTH
WTHATANLTEAH INHAD PPES ESAR
NOMEE THSA RHI TNGS UIEQREUS
SU MTOEACE SREUCFA OSSR BYURILE
NEIAITCRER.
MEVENANE ORTHROHE T PIAMGRS
HAIBES DCRAY TEDOD TWH, ATSHI
NTINAONS DSEE IMP EANXAM FLERO
ITD ECELTES ADLEERVI PINRONGDI
IRE THSPANUAITL LMOD RA
LE WSHERIPO CHHI NMSOGPRRAOR F
RIMATEGR PALRON S ESCAY.TISASF
AB LALE L,IN UETS YOIRSPE GUN
ANERAMIC AWIS TH OEN SSEF
NTTECIMENSA , SEESOFE  DNYTI,
A  IE NSOFMEOLNVVE, NTIN
G ETMEINALE THCH WNGLEESFAE CE
HIIN TT GRS EA ORIPEODOUF R
Y.STHIOR
ONARHE TN  GTHE EYO NGOI TVEHA
NSY ANSEATOFE  SIOFAISCTINN
LIEITHR S.VE
EAE THGRRISTTE P ALEVIGE
ALVIDIDUAVAN C HIS TSERVENIN
SE C AAUR IG BGEIMANTH H
.
AVWE H ASUE CH.AU CSE
HOZE SWEEIHE OORTU ITINIES
HAIBES DCRAY TEDOD
IL WL
RMDETET E INNOURLYON OE,UT FUR
THBUT REFUE TUACF  OPEANE D
FR
INDOEEM WOHI TS  TD RLINHE
LA OHI TRDCETHF E URNTY.
MAVED GOGIE S  UTH, SDWIOMETH
IDEAO SMLI TTH WBEORHAOFY  T
TCH
E,LEALNGATO  STHCAME ARIAN C
L LFFUILSTS ITDE BY INOFHENGEI T
WOS'D'OPSTBE HLIFOE R RTBEY,
POR FOOPY,UNRTITROOR F PESGRS
ANFOACPEE PEALR L
LEOPS.
LA[APPE]US
>> Y W AREGCHAT